so let's start with Adam
um what what is your relationship with
the Hellraiser franchise were you
familiar with it yeah um so my
relationship kind of with the franchise
when I was growing up I watched uh a lot
of horror movies I mainly actually
watched them as uh I guess these are
like reruns on TV
um through AMC like through horror Fest
they'd have those sort of um like the
franchise like uh nights where you just
watch them sort of continuously and yeah
around like Halloween time I would just
get really into them and I think uh what
was really cool about them like working
on this was to sort of get to revisit
not only that but also the novella that
they um also used as a huge inspiration
for
um the story of this one so yeah that
was kind of my uh connection to the
world before this and how about you drew
were you familiar with the hell right is
a franchise I was familiar I was
traumatized when I was a kid watching
them
um I definitely can't definitely saw I I
believe it was the first one same thing
on TV
uh
and I think it was eight or nine or
something and
um it was really just I
it's so ingrained in pop culture too
that you know it was hard especially
around Halloween to kind of Escape like
the image the images of the cinebites
you know
um
but yeah I was I remember seeing it when
I was eight or nine and just being uh
distraught and like I couldn't get
Pinhead out of my mind
um but then it was great we got to we
got to revisit the films you know once
we started working on this and
um you know it was such it's just such
an interesting you know it's not really
a specific horror genre it's a lot of
different genres in one
and you can't really put your put your
finger on it I think that's what makes
it so scary so then Drew were you
worried at all about remaking such a
beloved franchise
yes terrified I was I was waking up
every day going like oh my God I hope we
do it justice I mean I I whatever I was
feeling I'm sure you know David the
director and Keith our producer I'm sure
they were feeling it to the 10th degree
but they uh they had such a clear
vision and outline and they'd worked so
hard on it and so long that uh they were
just so focused on the details
um so the world around it was already
built for us we just kind of had to show
up and do our jobs and and and have fun
but yeah it was it was it was I was
absolutely terrified to you know to kind
of helmet or you know to to start it how
about you Adam were you nervous about
taking on such a beloved franchise I I
was kind of more excited I'd say like I
I just I I was kind of a little bit like
I I think I may be like too much too
much watching of The Originals I I went
I almost finished all like I guess 10 of
them I got geared off towards the end
but I I was kind of just wanting to
immerse myself like fully in the lore
and try to understand to make it even
more specific when we got in there
um so then I felt like when I was there
I just kind of wanted to like Let It Go
and just [ __ ] you know be in it but
it um it was exciting I don't know yeah
I just I love horror and so I just I was
I was more excited and I'm like you know
what there's the Legacy that they have
and you know what we're honoring it but
also I feel like we're bringing some new
stuff in so
um I hope people will appreciate it for
that can you guys talk about
um what it was like playing or using the
lament configuration boxes dude yeah
they were so cool I mean the the level
of like precision and also like dynamics
of them I mean I don't know brockard can
probably speak to it but there was like
so many different iterations of that
puzzle box and when it would move to
there's new configurations you know
there's like liminal and a lot around
there's all these different ones and so
um getting to sort of like see as they
moved in real time was so cool because
as I understand it like a lot of times
in The Originals they would have to
switch out them so as but in real time
some of them were morphing once had we
had ones that could actually morph into
different configurations and also sing
Odessa who plays Riley figure them out
in real time was like
uh so helpful for my character when I
get to see her do it on screen because
it was like she was actually figuring it
out and she got to be like best friends
with this box by the end essentially
because she was just she knew it like
the back of her hand so yeah I was I was
jealous of Odessa because she got to she
got to handle them so much like I was
always I felt like I always had to ask
permission like can I hold it and they'd
be like okay but they they have like
such a you know they have like a weight
to them uh there's probably probably
dozens of of
replicas made of like different versions
and different configurations
so yeah it was it was so well designed
and David knew David knew like every
single marketing on there like he was so
specific and and making it as
um kind of original as possible so yeah
it was great but I was still I was very
jealous I wanted to hold it all the time
and
um I know that you guys did a lot of
um practical effects as opposed to like
CGI effects do you have a favorite one
that you can talk about oh I
um I think that the weeper was very cool
because she the way that she walked I
mean it's it's like not just you know
the uh costume it's how they moved as
well and she sort of had like a clunky
sort of like creepy Vibe and she's so
tall so just like see this sort of like
clumping giant it was just it was
terrifying yeah yes some of the a lot of
the blood work and um like Adam like
your what the wires attached to you is
was really awesome
um I had like a wound in it with uh
essentially like a mark on my arm that
they had to they had to feed a tube
through underneath the Prosthetics and
then manually pump blood out like it
felt like we were making it felt like we
were making like a you know like I feel
like I was making a film with my friends
or something like for Halloween it was
it was really really cool
dream of it too right like it was yeah
so I'm watching I'm literally watching
like blood ooze out of me and in my mind
some does something in your brain where
you're like this is actually happening
um so yeah I was it was it was like
being a kid like on set it was so fun
awesome well thank you so much guys I
really appreciate it it was a really fun
movie thank you